thank you for
attending the workshops and staying to
the end
the best is still to come
if i can introduce councillor paul
eppingham
paul is
chairman of mid-suffolk district council
i knew i'd get it there or thereabouts
many thanks paul paul's going to round
things up for us today
thanks ian can everyone hear me okay
well a very good afternoon to all of you
um what a truly fantastic day's been um
thank you all for attending today's
local energy showcase it's been a real
eye-opener so i hope you have found the
day interesting and has and it has
answered some of your questions
i would like to give a huge thank you to
our sponsors who have helped to make
this event possible
especially to the co-op for the use of
this venue at no cost
always very welcome from a council point
of view i would also like to thank our
wonderful speakers who put into
perspective the importance of green
energy and sustainability
our appreciation also goes out to you
our guests who have made the event such
a success
we have a wide glass we have discussed a
wide range of topics with expert
speakers
heard from real life case studies
and wasn't peter dao a bit of a blast
wasn't he
i mean real life experience so you know
there's a guy to go to
and of course we've taken part in
workshops to find out how we can all
benefit from local energy for a brighter
future
i hope you come away from today's event
with some valuable knowledge on how you
can make an important change
by committing to our county-wide aim of
becoming carbon neutral by 2030 and
that's a big challenge for all of us
during the net zero in practice panel
session we had some in-depth discussions
and answers that will give us that push
that we need to put these ideas into
practice
i hope that before too long we will see
a positive impact from the decisions we
make as a result of what we've learned
today
so today we gained more understanding
about the benefits of solar energy
what communities within the region are
already doing
how to start our own sustainable journey
energy journey and how to access the
support available to local parishes
we hope you come away from today's
events knowing your bright ideas can
become a reality
babe mid-suffolk district councils have
stated our commitment for suffolk to be
carbon neutral and to continue down the
path of sustainability
this is not a one-time fix and then
return to the old ways
those ways are behind us now
going forward we will all be taking
great steps to make our homes a reality
your attendance here today has proved
that reducing the impact of climate
change is an important issue for
communities right now
we are incredibly grateful to everyone
here who is doing their very best to
embrace new energy solutions to move
towards a brighter greener future
before i wrap up i would like to give a
very big shout out to everyone who made
today possible particularly the baba mid
suffolk teams
and a big thank you to all of you all
thank you very much
[Applause]
i hope like me you have been energized
by what you have heard today
dan and tom's comments really resonated
with me and i'm very pleased that we at
baby mitzvah have adopted strategies to
address some of these issues
so let's turn today's knowledge into
practical solutions and take a leap
towards our new carbon neutral lives
we will be gathering feedback so we can
come back next time with an even bigger
and better event so we can learn from
each other from the work that we would
have done in the meantime
and by the way also a recording of this
event will be available on our youtube
channel in due course
so once again thank you all and have a
lovely weekend
[Applause]
you